pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's time to set this [ __ ] herb
man free [ __ ]
are you kidding me or what mad flavor
here wishing you a beautiful
[ __ ] Wednesday understand me
it's a beautiful day to be alive the
birds are chirpin the [ __ ] music is
singing all around him people are happy
to jumping up and down you know plan and
all we have to do is just most of we get
our goals down and [ __ ] this day right
the [ __ ] mount you understand it
because without [ __ ] confidence you
got no guts I'm gonna leave do it I'm
fat I smoked reefer enough from these I
don't give a [ __ ] when I walk into the
room I'm the president rock'n'roll I
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] your ego [ __ ]
your mother [ __ ] you degree I don't give
a [ __ ] jack we're taking over this
[ __ ] you understand me we got
some tremendous reefer today listen this
is all reliable you know me I swing with
[ __ ] perennial the [ __ ] perennial
old Jeep and this is Caruso from Sunset
aeropolis it's been killing [ __ ] but
enough is enough Joey are you gonna
spark this [ __ ] thing we just have to
sit here let's mark this
oh oh Jesus Christ I like smoking reefer
and I smoking joints but don't give me
the [ __ ] kicked at this one lizardom
you'll death here I clean this every
week that's a [ __ ] mule there's no th
not then nothing but [ __ ] bomb
diggity
you smoke dishes but hearing flies
[ __ ] mosquitoes like I said when you
buy reefer do you have mosquitoes
ambulances you [ __ ] boy that ATM you
take out another [ __ ] yardstick and
go buy as much refund as you can Jack
hearing things it will feel and I as one
but for inherent things as tremendous
ooh
anyway they got changed
Rosemont October 15th two shows Saturday
night
I'm laying it down in one of my favorite
[ __ ] cities in the world Chicago who
is my lady what are you [ __ ] crazy
the one
[ __ ] Bon Appetit [ __ ] it's time
it's time for [ __ ] death my two legs
you're tearing me apart that there are
two legs down pat man down you [ __ ]
nuts a little clean in the morning
office night at the [ __ ] op rumors
last time you listened for that [ __ ]
masterpiece way before he had to hear
he's a [ __ ] savage Freddie burger
no mater the ball the rifle yong-chol
jelly into one you don't get hurt nobody
I saw nobody which is here talking
getting stronger
when we get out there nobody for fun
with you because that's the call it a
day bro seven days a week nobody [ __ ]
you you never come home
you understand me whether it's internet
Brown a heavy hand a [ __ ] voice
listen [ __ ] you better check yourself
because you don't know who the [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] with you understand me
I'm just trying to spread some [ __ ]
love and reefer and you're here
insulting me you would suck to me a
little bit yes you did now go home and
get your [ __ ] shine box [ __ ] before
I shove it up your [ __ ] ass that's
the attitude you gotta have when you
leave it they [ __ ] these [ __ ] ain't
better than you they don't put their
pants on they put that pants on one leg
at a time just like you [ __ ] these
[ __ ] I may not have money and
I'm in that special that's the gift God
get I don't give a [ __ ] Jackie put your
pants on I got a [ __ ] time I'm gonna
come up to you call me Shirley I got
good stuff
Clemmie [ __ ] cuban I got good stuff I
can't imagine you white [ __ ]
linguist blood [ __ ] German [ __ ] Irish
so don't stare at me looking at me like
I did something [ __ ] wrong I'm gonna
stick up for yourself
there you go and if you can't beat them
[ __ ] wait it out like a [ __ ] snake
in the tree and when they least expect
it bah boom there you are with a big
dick in a bag a man comes and [ __ ] you
think you're dealing all this [ __ ]
okey doke [ __ ] I got one for
the grave on a banana people slowly you
you ain't got time to take your dally
with these [ __ ] you ain't got
time to bleed you wanna do something you
do it you want something you [ __ ]
take it see what it later David [ __ ]
[ __ ] you they better wake up and
apologize [ __ ] cuz Uncle Joe isn't
full of fact legit pseudo-classes no
meaning at two and then we got the bag
asset to rewrite and tonight I'm doing
something for Felicia's for you and I'm
the [ __ ] program I don't know what
the [ __ ] to tell you Pittsburgh
I could taste that [ __ ] Primanti
sandwich right now understand
I'm gonna smoke the joint and blow it on
the Roberto Clemente statue mother bring
that [ __ ] back the life of
interrupted stars a debt of this [ __ ]
cleats before the day is over one more
Porto Rican his back you understand me
because there was nobody like [ __ ]
Roberto Clemente you better check
yourself before you wreck yourself
checker Roberto Clemente's [ __ ]
resume what and that was a Puerto Rican
in the [ __ ] late sixties seventies
when you get him Sam but I'm gonna back
you dive if you have no idea of [ __ ]
makes 9 amp they got a bit gonna [ __ ]
cry dawg that's my heart Jack Lambert
that's my heart
Jack ham are you [ __ ] getting neither
like you're [ __ ] Kenny me
[Music]
then you have a pirate will [ __ ] Gabi
man and [ __ ] start without afraid
you're [ __ ] kidding me
penguins but listen don't give me
anxiety
I can't wait to grow the steel [ __ ]
hurt you bad [ __ ]
just the one neck neck the one this
country was at one time makes me [ __ ]
sad okay there was no PC in Pittsburgh
all they know is how the head you would
have [ __ ] in black and yellow helmet
and if there was no concussion so we had
to think mean joke breather
I got a conclusion I thought no sure you
don't think I'm excited about Pittsburgh
you got another thing [ __ ] come I'm
even [ __ ] parachute off the plane
with a [ __ ] big dick up my parachute
say you suck my dick anyway if you
haven't noticed I'm stone for the gills
it happens you know like I said we don't
put our pants
but that's it
are you dare enter this house
Fitchburg I love you guys I'll see you
later on the podcast should we smoke
another one what do you think you may
have for fire Joey
we'll finish this one down
you know listen now get your [ __ ]
together a daily basis
[Music]
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] [ __ ] these fake
[ __ ] pot smokers and uncle Joey's the
one who's bang allow you [ __ ]
every day you ever think about you ever
think of fine that will experience what
water respect cuz that's how we [ __ ]
roll in this family
ha
you know it's gonna be a good day either
national anthem in you pissed
that's that second [ __ ] frozen the
Rockets red gave proof are you [ __ ]
kidding me on what that our flag was
still there
you understand me is the flag salute
this [ __ ] going here
[Music]
all right that's the one that killed
Kelly I love you [ __ ] have a
great day
stay black keep you guys don't know
nobody [ __ ] we remember to keep going -
employee I don't know who won on Ito
latina leave that Tortosa
sopping wet coat your Somali get there
mama need to voice out but go easy at
the Americana I told I never said one
break and you know when the Apollo a
pillar he thought a hint immediately my
mama not being as I cannot be nervous
wrong Camille I say simple a banana I
love you guys when this young stay black
today's your lucky [ __ ] day make it
happen